Yeah,
so there's this interesting phenomenon
that it's very characteristic of,
of,
of societies,
I believe pretty much everywhere it's
being studied.
Now you can calculate an index called
the Gini Coefficient.
The Gini Coefficient is a number that
represents how much inequality of income
distribution there isn't a given
geographical area.
So you could calculate a Gini
Coefficient for a street or a,
you know,
an area in a city or a city or a state
or a country.
You can do it at all those levels.
And uh,
what you find is,
you know,
you always hear this idea that poverty
causes crime.
That's a classic leftwing idea,
but it's wrong,
it's seriously wrong and it's
importantly wrong.
And it's definitively wrong.
Not only that,
so there's no argument about this.
It's already been established.
What causes crime,
especially aggressive crime is relative
poverty and relative poverty is not the
same thing as poverty at all.
It's seriously not the same thing.
Poverty is when you don't have enough to
eat.
Relative poverty is when the guy next
door has a much better car than you.
So,
and there's lots of relative poverty in
the United States.
And there's some absolute poverty,
but even the absolute poverty in the
United States is nothing like the
absolute poverty say in places like
India or in Subsaharan Africa where
absolute poverty means you have nothing.
Now what's really interesting about the
Gini Coefficient is that if you go to
places where everyone,
roughly speaking is poor,
say by national standards.
I think South Dakota was often used as
an example or maybe one of the maritime
provinces like Newfoundland,
where there's where there's low average
income,
but it's pretty flat distribution.
There's almost no crime.
And if you go to the places where the
everyone's rich,
then there's almost no crime.
But if you go places where there were
poor people and moderately well off
people and rich people and the
distribution is really steep,
then the rate of aggressive behavior
among young men and it's usually within
their own ethnic group,
starts to spot skyrocket out of the
control.
And the reason for that seems to be that
if the dominance hierarchy is too steep
than the young men have no likelihood of
climbing to a dominant position well
playing the standard social game.
And so what they do is turn to
aggression,
aggression to,
to make their mark on the world.
And it works too.
That's the other thing is that make no
mistake about it.
If you're,
if you're looking for status in a place
where status is hard to achieve and
you're the meanest,
toughest guy around then and you know,
around a bunch of people who like,
you don't have much money,
then you're going to benefit from that
status if it works.
Yeah.
Because they know that I,
that is higher than it is in Canada
reason.
Sure,
sure.
Yeah.
I mean you can make a real conservative
argument for making sure that the
conservatives are very anti income
distribution and we figured that's
because of the guys that have this male
independence,
you know,
they identify with this male
independence factor.
They don't want to be distributing
resources to people who are down in the
dominance hierarchy because they will.
They want them down in the dominance
hierarchy.
They want there to be a difference
between the people on top and the people
on the bottom so that they can be the
people on top.
So that it increases the relative
attractiveness,
like it's a perfectly logical game and
they presume that while the rules are
set up and like every man can go for it,
do as fast in the winter winds and the
loser loses and that's just how it is.
And don't ask me to fix it because I
don't want to,
you know.
And besides that it's,
I don't find it,
I find it distasteful to attempt to fix
it more than that.
Right?
Because it's a moral issue.
It's not an intellectual issue.
So.
So you,
you can make a case however you can make
a case from the conservative point of
view,
especially with regards to say beliefs
and religious traditionalism and the
desire to maintain social stability that
you shouldn't let income distribution
become two unequal.
Like one of the big things your society
has to do is to make sure that that
doesn't get out of hand because it tends
to get out of hand.
It tends towards a few people having
everything and almost everyone else
having nothing.
It's a natural in a sense.
It's a natural consequence of economic
progression,
which is actually something that marks
pointed out,
although an Italian name,
peritoneal had figured it out at
approximately the same time and I think
with a lot more conceptual clarity,
but the more unequal you let your
society get,
the higher the probability of death
roughly speaking through through violent
causes and you know,
um,
but,
but I'm telling you why it is that,
you know,
men want to climb the dominance
hierarchy and the reason they want to
call them the dominance hierarchies
because that's how they get access to
women
fucking familiar,
familiar in the structure.
So it seems like we all want to live
within the structure yourself.
Well,
we have this contradictory problem.
We want to be protected by the
structure,
but we want to advance our position
within it.
And so that means what that should mean.
And this is,
I think the definition of civilized
behavior is that you're allowed to
advance your position within the
structure as long as you don't disrupt
it negatively.
You know,
and I think most people do do that.
In fact,
I think people in civilized countries do
that so effectively that it's an
absolute incomprehensible miracle.
I can't understand how or why it ever
got established,
but like a psychopath will.
He climbed the ladder and cut the rungs
off underneath them fundamentally,
right?
It's like he doesn't care.
He doesn't even care if the damn thing
maintains itself.
You know,
he's perfectly willing to have it
destroyed after he's exhausted it,
you know,
but if everyone acted like that,
or even if a fairly substantial
percentage of people acted like that,
the whole thing would come to a halt,
virtually like in no time flat.
So,
so mean.
Why?
See?
You might hear.
Here's the reason.
Likely,
you know,
because one of the things we were
talking about was masculine violence.
Now the thing about masculine violence
is it only tends to emerge in situations
where there doesn't.
There don't seem to be any other
reasonably viable means of advancing
status.
So it's not reasonable to say that men
are aggressive.
You can say that on average,
men are more aggressive than women.
And you can also say that if that if you
put men in a situation where they have
no,
where they can see status differences,
but they have no means of moving
forward,
that they're likely to turn to
aggression as a way of establishing
dominance.
And then you can say that that's the
reason for that is because it makes them
more attractive.
What are the fundamental reasons
I read this article was about how
societies are.
Yeah,
absolutely.
When one guy has two wives,
I mean 50 percent of the population have
access to sex.
Yeah,
that's exactly right.
That the,
the,
the evolutionary psychology explanation
for the pathology of polygamy is that
if,
once you let it establish itself,
then the men get ultra violent.
So.
So would you say that
many people have said that and.
Yes,
I think you can make a strong case for
that.
And I think the fundamental reason is
the one that you just pointed out,
you know,
the idea is,
well,
would you rather have one woman or die
now or sorry,
that's not quite right.
Would you rather know next?
Not Quite.
That's not quite right.
Would you,
it's more like,
would you be willing to limit yourself
to one partner or have a shot at many
partners but a much higher probability
of dying?
Right.
And you know,
some guys will take that,
they'll take the high risk approach,
you know,
so now if this doesn't delineate the
difference in individual differences in
determining who's going to be
aggressive,
because what'll happen is that as the
Gini Coefficient pressure rises,
the more aggressive men,
the men who were more aggressive by
nature will get more aggressive first.
Right?
So you could imagine there it's a
threshold phenomena in some sense.
So add,
I,
I should tell you as well as the
relationship between the Gini
Coefficient and male on male homicide
isn't like point two or point three,
which is about the correlation that
you'd get if you were predicting
something like that.
Using personality.
It's like point eight or point nine.
It's like it eats up all of it.
It's explanation.
So it's a huge effect.
You know,
it's so,
it's so big in affected.
You could basically say,
oh well we figured that out.
Although psychologists never know when
they figured anything out in,
they keep endlessly retesting it over
and over and over because you know,
we don't know how to bring our science
to a stock,
but if you don't accept the Gini
Coefficient aggression down,
it's like you might as well throw the
rest of the social sciences out the
window because the effect is
unbelievably powerful.
Let you go.
It depends.
You can do it at any level of analysis.
You can do it,
you can do it by county,
you can do it by city,
you can do it by state and you can do it
by country and it works on all of those
levels.
Predicted aggression.
You
Bet.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and that's a great question.
I mean the methodologically
sophisticated studies have done exactly
that to ensure that while to ensure that
it's actually this phenomena rather than
other factors that might be operative in
that particular geographical area.
So countries with a higher GDP,
Gini Coefficient or more violent and
cities within that country that have a
higher than average Gini Coefficient for
that country are more violent.
On average.
What's a very,
very robust,
robust,
robust finding.
So.
Alright,
so we're good.
We're going to say for the sake of
argument that you've got the male
dominance hierarchy and it's represented
as masculine.
No.
One of the things young said,
he thought that women carried an image
of Matt Nan in their unconscious and
she,
he thought that the image that women
carried of men in their unconscious with
a group of men,
not an individual matt,
he called that the animus.
Whereas he believed that the image that
women image of women that men carried in
their collective unconscious was of a
single woman and he called that the
anima.